all right so give us our first 3x3 okay
okay so what the [__] is we've got okay
it's over here now Okay so we've got
clanard or Clan after story is that
Gundam Seed Gundam Seed is that Gundam
Seed I really hope it's not Gundam Seed
we have princess monoke we have Rama
half we have
orimo God did you make
this we have welcome to the NHK we have
Naruto potentially shipuden we have
hajim IO and we have yuu Haka oh this is
tough who the [__] would make this list
can you pull up the name okay okay I'm
I'm there is one big like indicator here
even without looking at the guest names
uh are you sorry are you put
absolutely on the
background like absolutely 100% this
person grew up in the same era as myself
because there is no [__] way someone
would put Gundam Seed on their list if
it was wasn't the very first Gundam and
maybe the only Gundam that they've
watched you know that's if you've seen
any other Gundam you would not put seed
on you that's what I'm saying and no
like nobody else would put it unless
it's like the first Gundam You' put on
there yeah wasn't I think Gundam Seed
when it was airing uh on Cartoon Network
or something I don't know where it aired
uh it was like the most popular show on
in the entire network West I think I
actually might know who this is because
from the list we've been given there is
only one person I know that would have
the have the balls to put seed on here
and also has openly expressed how much
they love Clan ad and
orimo can't no I think it's
dius uh it would make a lot of sense he
does love he loves clanet he loves hajim
Mano he loves orimo and he would put he
like he likes Haj oo yeah I've never
heard him talk about haoo before he's
mentioned Ramah half before yeah I so I
reckon this is di I see the degeneracy
like I I know a fellow brother when I
see one and then someone like put ormo
right slap Bank in the center as I would
have done and I think I did do actually
uh see I can already see it right like
didus is like you know he's he's listing
off like the obvious ones that
immediately come to his head like Oro
and like princess monoke H you know CL
stuff like that and his attempt to seem
cultured is him welcome to the
NHK you know what I mean he's like no no
no I actually I it's not all the
mainstream stuff I love I also watch
other ones like welcome to the NHK but
he also forgets welcome to the NHK it's
Mega horny as well which is also very
dieus is this
dius yes we know our friends R you like
a book he does I don't know anyone in
this day and age who still references
Naruto as much as him I don't know
anyone else who references he just
always says something narut yeah but is
that anything like uh special I don't
know I feel like a lot of people
reference Naruto I feel like narative
reference is becoming less common G
generation yeah that's what I'm saying
like it's I'm sure this is how like I
don't know this there probably some
older equivalent involved here that's
true uh I feel like he he Springs up
narrator more than anyone else or any
normal amount any any any allowed amount
should it should be brought up that is
true that is true um one thing that
surprises me being on here I'm really
hoping you have seen more Gundams or
this is I'm just I'm just not I'm I
don't think he's seen more okay so I
don't know what's so bad about Gundam
Seed can you explain to me why Gundam
Seed is bad and what what even it is
well it's a Gundam for one okay great um
it was just I don't know like have you
seen any Gundam
no and there's probably a fair amount of
viewers watching you haven't seen any
Gundam so so when most people when most
people bring up what their favorite
Gundams are and I'm talking like the you
know the kind of older the first half of
the Gundam franchise right A lot of
people bring up like Wing a lot of
people bring up double zero is a very
common one
seed like I don't know how do you I'm
trying to figure out the words to
describe why seed is questionable it's
hard uh it's not hard it's just uh the
writing quality [__] jumped off a
cliff in especially in the second season
uh it's that one Gundam that's got mega
mega popular uh I mean you mentioned
wing and uh double O I don't think any
of them hold a candle to how popular
seed got back in the day and it was one
of those Gundams that you look at the
entire history of Gundam right you look
at this entire franchise with how many
shows there are and then it's this one
that gained the mega mainstream
popularity and it's just confusing
because probably right place right time
May it's the sword on line equivalent
you know holy [__] that is actually that
is actually oh my God that is actually
the Perfect Analogy it's the seed is
seed is to the mecca franchise as Sword
Art was to the isaki franchise where it
was just right place at the right time
mega mega popular but not the best
writing at in any stretch of the mean
yeah and you watch Gundam Seed and that
might be your introduction to gundam and
then you watch any other Gundam and
you're like oh this is [__] yeah yeah
and uh this is like or you watch even
like any other Mecca show and you
realize how uh I don't remember what is
what is Gundam Seed out of 10 on a scale
if you had to give it a rating like a
five for me like five six it's pretty
brutal especially after the second
season there's more coffee I need more
coffee do we have do we have a reason
why he does did he say why he chose the
things he chose he didn't give any
reason he didn't give any reasons have
given reasons as to
why I do know for a fact that daus
always talks about how much he loves
romance and Slice of Life shows yeah uh
and so I'm assuming that's why clanet
after Story is on here oh he loves like
if you want to if you want to meet
someone who loves clanet more than I do
it's daus like daus [__] loves clad
which is based he also loves Ora as well
which is not based my I like d is like a
[__] brother to me man every time I
watch a trashy romance show
I I know he's like I message him and
he's always into the same [__] you know
we both [__] love Oro he gets the
Masterpiece that his domestic girlfriend
as well who understands that [__] well
well dadus just likes car crashes yeah
that's the thing when I when I talked to
dadus about shows he often if he one
thing that he always makes very apparent
is that if he feels like he can predict
what's going to happen he's not
interested right yeah yeah and I guess
the reason why he likes Oro and perhaps
maybe domestic
girlfriend is such car crashes that he
doesn't know where it's going yeah um
that is true to me that is an indication
of a show that's good there's an
indication of sure is just trying to
subvert expectations sure and of course
if you're going to [__] your brother
that's pretty that's a good way to
subvert I wouldn't say so okay let let
me let me defend the [__] trashy
romance genre okay because I'm I'm
addicted okay actually do you know do
you know what I did in the Christmas
holiday I don't know if you would be you
know if you know what this is Joe I
watched White Album to
you watch White Album too yeah I [__]
know it okay my question is you could
have watched anything else because and
you watched White Album to because uh it
was the one [__] Car Crash romance
that I just did not watch what the [__]
is White Album too imagine school days
but
withouts imagine school days but without
the murdering and it's about that it's I
actually think it's on the same level of
school days in terms of like the pure
[__] shitty reaction and the car
crash of an ending that you got this
like look at this this scream's like mid
2000 trash originally it was originally
an aray I think or at least a visual
Noel probably an AR from the mid 2000s
uh got mega mega popular in the Doan
world yeah uh and uh and then when the
anime came out I I watched it when it
came out and uh I uh you know i' had
forgotten about it until you brought it
up and I'm really glad I'm really hoping
you didn't bring it up this was this was
an ending where they set up a they set
up like a love triangle I [__] love
this [__] they set up a love triangle
and then the author just sets everything
on fire and I [__] love that [__] man
that's you just described a mid2 huh
sounds stressful I mean okay maybe maybe
it's because I'm in a you know happy
relationship that this is like I I to to
feel something anymore I need this kind
of romance I need this kind of story in
my life man because like my my real my
real life I'm like it's too solid your
real life you need you need some [__]
SP I need some spice up in there
imagination's going to get to the point
where the only thing that'll like get
his socks rocking is just playing the
most egregious AR out there from the M
2000s cuz all of them are like that no
but I've I've always liked you know car
crash kind of romanes just because it
gives you an emotional response like you
are you know like it's kind of like
drama YouTube you know except no one's
getting hurt it's like no no one's
actually doing something outrageous it's
all in a place of fantasy and fiction
that makes sense but again over the
Christmas holidays you could have
watched literally anything bro I had a
great time man I got [__] plastered
and I watched White Album with Sydney
and we [__] shouted at the screen for
what all the characters were doing and
it was a great [__] time this is the
wee equivalent to watching sports bro
no no this is the wee equivalent to
watching N St fiance and being like yo
they did what no she said what yo she
slept with him wait wait this [__] this
[__] came back and the she thinks that
she can take over again ain't no way no
it's it's a great time sounds like
horrible
time um one that I am kind how was this
that you were defending Oro yeah
yeah so Oro is just that the ending to
or MO is just one of like seeing the
reaction to the internet to the ending
of Aro was one of the most funnest per
like weekends I've had in my life just
seeing the internet melt down that was
me with school days bro that was me with
school days yeah we seeing the ending to
school days and then just Japanese
internet just being like what the [__]
did I just [__] watch see with with
school days I didn't I I guess I was
like on forums and on social media less
I was on tan
tan caught on Flames that day what was
the reaction like to that dude everyone
was like wait so was this like an April
fo's joke this actually is this the
actual like no that they're setting up
for a final final episode right no it
wasn't and people got mad as [__] but
but it was really weird it was so
egregious that half the internet with a
stable mind was like this is the worst
[__] ending I've ever seen and then
the other half of tan was like that was
an absolute masterpiece
I have a question about Oro yes I
actually don't know what the [__] Oro is
about all I know is that there's incest
that's only from you I actually wait
have you never seen it no cuz it has
incest I don't want to watch that well I
mean it's not the whole way
through just a little bit it's literally
okay let me let me explain to you let me
explain to you just a little bit of in
just a little bit all right let me
explain to you why the internet [__]
broke down in uh because people don't
[__] believe me when I say this but
uh
it was a show that deated all of us it
like pulled like a reverse UNO card
because rmo in season one came out and
it was a show called uh my little sister
can't be this cute right and then
everyone was meing on it because haha
it's uh it's a [__] show called
[__] my little sister can't be this
cute obvious incest bait and then you
actually watch season one and people
were like wait they're actually like
acting like real brother and sister like
actual siblings and it turns out to be a
like a
pretty interesting look on otaku and
like Akihabara culture in Japan okay
because this came out before there was
this huge wave of hey this is like wee
culture uh this is a look into
Arab when was it 8 n something like that
something something around that time and
so it was a genuinely interesting and
good show that people hadn't seen before
with what at the time felt like a more
realistic depiction of a brother and
sister in anime and then season 2 came
out and uh that it kind of went it
turned into this kind of Slice of Life
look into otaku culture into more of
like a typical Haram best girl kind of
like show where every girl around him
falls for the main character okay n got
robbed bro yeah yeah exactly and then
they released the last three episodes as
an OVA where spoiler he chose his sister
after the first seon everyone's like no
this this ain't an in this ain't an Inc
like kiss or something or yeah that's
only the beginning what they they they
got uh married uh that's that was the
like end of the show yeah uh they got
like fake married um and then they broke
up because they were brother and sister
because it was illegal yeah and it was
just seeing the internet [__] go into
flames because of the author just being
like haha this this isn't actually an
incest show just like just joking
actually it was incest the entire time
you guys fell for my reverse baits it it
was just everyone broke down the author
is such a godamn troll because then
because then afterwards he was just like
I'm going have to go in and made
ARA this just round two yeah the big
difference between Oro and aranga Sensei
is aranga Sensei just didn't even
pretend and for from episode one it was
just like genuinely there was a time
when I thought Oro for like season one
genuinely I think it's a good show
uh sense say that was always that was
always in the trash man that was always
to to give orimo the benefit of the
doubt it did as G said have a lot of
interesting aspects to it that was
actually created a compelling story even
for a harm anime yeah but my problem
with it is that it didn't follow through
with that the end and and the author was
just like Noah I'm going to make some DJ
[__] instead so what about this do you
think maybe was so compelling to
daus because obviously G this is a big
show favorite of yours what about it do
you think it'd be so compelling to be in
the top nine to me ormo was the first
show that I would say turned me into a
weeb I would say before Oro okay here's
here's here's here's what I'm for what
reason G for what re okay here's the
difference before Aro right I was I I
went through this kind of like
pretentious critic I I have good taste
kind of like you you know everyone goes
through that phase where they're like oh
I went through the Mal top 100 that's my
taste I like Legends of the galactic
heroes I like all of the classics you
just described me in 203 and then and
then Oro and then I watch ormo and I'm
like huh the first I was get I went into
this ready to [__] in it and the first
season I was like wait a minute this is
enjoyable but this goes against
everything that I thought I enjoyed and
I think for I think because at the time
this was a very kind of like original
take on it or very new take on it I
think that was the first kind of like
show for a lot of people uh in my
generation where it was I think and I
think people still gravitate to it even
now because even though it came out in
2010 there have been so many Oro clones
that have come out since then that have
tried to like replicate that feeling of
the show to not that much success
because people just see right through it
this day and age or mode doesn't stand
out as much anymore because there's like
a million different shows that revolve
around but it does stand out in a sense
because it I would say out of all of the
Oro clones and all the shows that kind
of bit off orimo orimo still does orimo
best if that makes sense yeah because
there was a point where it was genuinely
I think a good show yeah and then every
every every show copied the second half
of the oruro show uh welcome to the NHK
I hear a lot of people talk very
positively about this one of the shows
that's been on my like I'm SAR I'm going
to watch this at some point and I never
fastic show that is the the anti Oro
Mega depressing yeah it also deals with
otaku culture except the [__]
depressing side yeah from my
understanding it just seems about like a
show who guy a guy struggling with um
how to that's why be normal yeah it's
kind of Welcome to the NHK I think is
one of the best anime that uh tackles
yeah I didn't want one wel welcome to
the NHK is one of the best shows in my
opinion that tackles the idea of
loneliness in Japan okay uh because you
know you're talking it's definitely
going to be on camera of G spilling or
something great but um yeah so like yeah
as as G said like you know if if the
ideal Wee World is the main character of
Oro then the total opposite of that is
the main character of w the NHK where
like him being ostracized and him
feeling lonely as a result of being in
otaku and struggling to connect to
people through his hobbies and his
interests is the entire philosophy of w
to the NHK bit more of a real take isos
Oro this is this is just sister this is
just if boj Jack Horseman was a weeb
that is welcome to the NHK that's okay
you so me okay
you it's it kind of yeah it deals with
exactly asessing as Bojack it's [__]
depressing it's pretty depressing is
pretty depressing because it's I mean
you know about hii right this is the
main character is a hiimori and he the
entire show is him struggling to [__]
not become a hiimori and actually become
a member of society um and sounds like a
great show [__] hard he he just it's
brutal like this was before this came
out before kind of like the whole mental
health um awareness was more of a thing
now in this day and age and it's so
weird to see this coming out back in the
day before that conversation was really
as prevalent as it is now it's very Po
and even now yeah and it still hits just
as hard um and you know it's just it's
just so funny just hearing the dichotomy
between Oro and this you're like yeah
yeah he [__] his sister get married yeah
it's not a bad thing and you're like so
he's just trying to be a normal human
being like damn that's tough yeah I I
can I can really see like like like it's
like [__] your sister easy pill to
swallow function in a member of society
[__]
that's it's like why why are we at the
world where these two shows are
described in this D was really like
double dipping into like the otaku world
like at both ends of the spectrum of
like the Wee World with these two shows
uh I am surprised was U HW show though
I've never heard him talk about yuu Haw
show uh yeah I've never heard him talk
about it either if I knew I would
[__] geek out about yuu HW show with
him but yeah solid Choice presumably
very solid Choice it's it's literally
Shonen and weeb one of the best 90 shown
in shows in my op I think the most
important thing is that he also has RAR
on here as well also good so he just you
know dipping in all generations he's got
good taste yeah except for G except for
seed I don't know except for seed about
Naruto I mean Naruto is just Naruto
isn't it it's probably just shown a
number one that you first followed I
imagine it's like what whichever shown
you follow first for the longest time
see I don't know I'm looking at this and
I'm like was the first anime he ever
watched seed or was
Naruto I don't think does the first
matter that much it does cuz it kind of
sets up I I watch Naruto first and I
wouldn't put it and now you like Oro so
I mean there's a Nostalgia cells can't
for a reason people people tend to be
very even if they it might not be their
favorite they tend to have a
subconscious kind of um kind of tie to
the first real long show they watch
right um cuz princess monoke was
definitely his first anime film
guarantee princess monoke was my first
anime fil A film it's like a I mean it's
one of my favorite jiggly films yeah
it's one of my favorite as well still
haven't watched it what you never seen
one okay I think you would enjoy it
actually you would really like it
actually like adult Co yeah it's more
adult than something like Spirited Away
uh Spirited Away is a bit more trippy
cuz Spirited Away is just [__] weird
a lot of the time get trippy it's pretty
trippy yeah it's pretty trippy trippy as
[__] it's fantastic it's like that's
like those kind of films it's like
leaning forward you have to watch cuz
you're like oh [__] okay let me yeah on
okay in some some scenes it's just like
oh [__] okay they went there uh and then
of course hajo considered one of the
best sports anime of all time oh
absolutely it is amazing show one day I
will watch it yeah but it is long it is
long it's just long you have not watched
Haim upo no it's long if I have I've
lied
I I've said that I've watched it I've
lied you you would love it actually
every every every any single time I see
a clip from the show it looks so godamn
cool it's fun some of the most I think
hajo upo is some of the most hype you
could get in anime just period like when
I think about the hype anime what comes
up at the top it's something like Gan
Lagan I think is the ceiling of how hype
a a certain show can be Haim is like a
very very close second there for me in
terms of how hype I felt watching a
scene uh or just watching a piece of
fiction I've never had the adrenaline
rush of some of the scenes that have
happened in hajim noo have you seen you
Haw uh I've seen one episode one episode
yeah I think we spoke about this on a on
a podcast uh where I tried watching it
and I I I just I wasn't in the right
frame of M it also starts off slow as
well it's so slow first episode it's
like okay he di because Togashi didn't
know which direction he wanted to take
the story so it actually started off as
like kind of like a A Slice of Life show
until toachi was like all right I'm I'm
going to pull a dragon B route and just
do an action show yeah yeah all right
but that was daus's list which I think
uh accurately represents everything I
know about him very so I'm not going to
call out him out for lying so that that
definitely screamed his name good job
good job daus who is next all right